foreign
s us up next in Columbus Ohio Kate and
welcome to the show
thank you for having me absolutely
what's going on with you
um so I was just wondering about some
practical next steps I could take
um I'm pretty young I'm 18 years old and
I've just had like hurdle after hurdle
in my financial uh life I guess
um I back in September my car was
totaled and then I'm not really getting
paid much of my job I feel like I could
be making more don't have any debt
um and I just bought a bike as a resale
investment and engine that's blown and
so all my money is wrapped up on that
I'm at like score one right now
like 100 bucks what are you making at
your current job
um
20.
why are you only making 20.
um that's minimum wage if that
um yeah so it it's just a little bit of
a complicated situation but I'm working
for a family-owned company it's a small
company we make a bunch of like um
aftermarkets parts for quads like
suspension a arms we used to make swing
arms we also make a roll cages bumper
strums and stuff like that is this
full-time I feel like it could be it is
full-time are you making any money
uh my take home is about 630 bucks and
you can't live on average yeah you need
to go find a new job yesterday I know
it's your family and I know that you're
getting they're telling you you get good
experience and one day this will all be
yours but you're not making enough money
man
what was that
you're not making enough money you got
to go find another job
do you not believe you can make more
elsewhere tomorrow
um
I I mean the reason why I'm still with
the company um it's a family-owned
company but not by my family
um and the reason why I'm still with the
company is because
um I believe that there would be
something better there and so I was
actually working a second job with my
family uh Donatos actually and but that
was too much because I was doing like
100 hour weeks and stuff like that but
yeah how old are you
18. what do you want to be doing at 22.
at 22.
um I would like to be married uh what do
you want to do career-wise
career right career-wise
um take welding so I'm actually I take
well on all these parts
did you go to trade school for that or
you just learn on the Fly
oh I went to trade school so why not get
a welding dude at full time
yeah all your licensures and everything
yeah I actually graduated top of the
class of Marion
so dude what are you doing man I've got
a buddy who's a welder and he laughs at
my paychecks like he's doing quite well
are there no welding jobs in your
community
uh not not immediately around they know
have you checked have you called every
welder in town and said hey I graduated
top of the class I'd love to work for
you or call your college back and say
Hey I want to talk to the Career
Services Group
um
what I'm hearing is a guy who Who had
who got punched in the face a few times
and now doesn't think he's worth
anything and is like well maybe
eventually something will happen like
you're you're just like a passive person
in the story of your life and I want you
to believe that you're a main character
and that you have some control and right
now it feels like you're just waiting
for the next big thing to happen
yeah so I think you need to take a big
step because you've lost the wind in
your sales man and that step is I'm
gonna go believing Kaden and go find
another job that pays me what I'm worth
so that I can get ahead financially part
of the reason you're calling in saying I
can't get ahead financially is because
you're barely making ends meet making
600 bucks a month
oh well it is 600 bucks a week but I
mean it's
2400 bucks a month yeah and you have no
debt and you're still not feeling like
you can have traction and so you need to
find something where you get paid double
or triple what you're making now uh so
that you can hit your financial goals
I'm sure you want to be a homeowner one
day right
um and you want to have a big pile of
money in the bank
an emergency fund and you have other
goals things you want to do I'll also
tell you man you're not in a position at
18. I know dude I I have Instagram too
and George I don't know how Tick Tock
works but George shows me to his how the
tick tocks I know there's 18 and 19 year
olds all over it talking about bro this
is your way to the
you got dude you got to stop buying
projects and flips and I'm gonna buy
this bike I'm gonna flip it for this
dude
just take the boring route take the
boring smart route that has helped
millions and millions of people
build Financial Security man
and it just don't overthink it and don't
over but like George mentioned man you
want you're trying to be safe and I've
got this job and it's just cool and I
work a parent with my parents and it's
cool
but I'm just not getting anywhere well
then you gotta change something you
gotta change something and money only
works two ways you can make more of it
you can spend less of it that's about it
in fact that is it right and so if
you're not spending more then you got to
earn more so go go get it man Just Go
Get It Go Get It Go Get It yeah we're
cheering you on man thanks for the call